the fall convocation talk is given by
the professor of the year
this one is particularly delightful to
me
he will give the first speech by a baby
from this podium
uh like uh half the people in the county
he's the offspring of david and janet
whalen
so you can't turn around without running
into one of them
and uh this young man
how old have you been 35.
so i've known him since he was 15. see i
just
that was a subtraction problem
um what was he like when he was 15
well in in one way he's then exactly as
he will be when he's 80.
he's babyfaced uh
also he has that charming smile
an engaging way that just makes him seem
friendly he grew up with a bunch of
friends patrick did too
to at least two of the boys did and
they're like
really rough customers they played
rugby and they hurt each other all the
time and then they can sing like angels
and so of course there's larceny in the
boy
he and four of those boys three others
went to europe twice and bust
all over europe and came back with money
in their pocket
and i made them stand up in my house
years and years ago we've been pheasant
shooting the boy can shoot too
and uh we we cooked the pheasants and
we're eating them
and i made those boys they stopped by
and i made them sing and they really
could sing and then ben whelan looks to
dang pretty
you can see why people put a lot of
money in his bucket when he was singing
he was the whaling kid that was most
noticeable
he's going to be a college professor he
just has such an
open warmth for knowing things and such
a
ready ability to identify what is known
what is best to be known
he took up english i guess you'd say
like his daddy
um and i remember he went to the
university of dallas and he went to
university of nevada las vegas where
oddly enough there's a great english
professor
i remember it was a happy day when david
came in my office and said
the english department is interested in
hiring ben
for a one year appointment i said that's
the most
wonderful news and he said wonderful and
i said yeah i said you came to tell me
that you can't be involved in that
and that means that that boy belongs to
me
and then sure enough later they wanted
to make him stick around here
and then sure enough later he won the
professor of the year
he is a golden young man ben whalen
professor of the year
thank you dr arn that's a very kind
introduction
um i apologize to you all i as i stepped
on the platform my glasses broke
it seems somehow fitting in 2020 to
give an address to an audience i can't
see with a text i can't read
on june 12 1592
when the budding young actor shakespeare
was just 28 years old
and fresh on the scene of london a riot
rocked the english capital
apparently an apprentice to a felt maker
had been arrested
and thrown in prison under dubious
circumstances
his fellow felt-making apprentices
gathered in the southern district to
protest
it was an area pocketed with taverns and
theaters
and was where shakespeare performed the
protest drew a large crowd
and became violent supported as the
mayor of london described things by
quote a great number of loose and
masterless men apt for such purposes
as riot the mayor
william webb responded with vigor
arresting the principal and violent
actors of mariah
the elizabethan government was made
uneasy however
and when the rumor spread that the felt
maker apprentices
were planning a second tumult the privy
council
deployed an armed watch for bad certain
forms of public gathering
and shut down the theaters for three
months it was a hard blow for those who
had made the theater their profession
indeed the suspension of the theaters
lasted far longer
than the initially planned three months
in the
later in the year a large outbreak of
the bubonic plague swept through
england and as the government tried to
limit the spread of the plague
it forced the theaters to remain closed
for much of the next year and a half
what was shakespeare to do here was a
young man
just come to london just beginning his
career
facing a country convulsed by riots and
a deadly disease
shakespeare did what any of us would
have done in such a situation
he organized a zoom rendition of hamlet
notably with his means of employment
gone shakespeare turned to his poetry
producing the only narrative poems that
he ever wrote
venus and adonis and the rape of lucrece
both of these are some of the very
finest narrative poems
in our literary tradition being as an
adonis a playful meditation
on love and desire while the rape of
lucretia is a serious examination
of the nature of suffering the abuse of
power
the foundations of human government and
ancient rome's transition
from monarchy to republic we probably
would be willing enough
to excuse shakespeare had the plague
with its many deadly terrors and surely
daily nuisances and worries occupied all
his attention
and prevented him from writing or at
least writing well
we probably would be willing enough to
excuse shakespeare had his imagination
been occupied by visions of hordes of
felt making apprentices pouring down the
streets
felt in hand ready to light it and watch
london burn
[Music]
indeed it is rather remarkable that
although waves of the bubonic plague
swept through
england several times during
shakespeare's youth and adulthood
for instance he was the year he was born
it killed one out of every five people
in his hometown of stratford
one out of five shakespeare rarely
mentions it
in his works it is surprising
even perhaps a little odd to find how
little notice
how little attention shakespeare seems
to give
to this deadly disease it's almost as if
shakespeare
is calling us to look at other things
higher things
than the banal facts of disease and
death
and it's not that shakespeare is an
escapist in his poetry
nor is he a blinded idealist as i
mentioned
he wrote about suffering extensively but
shakespeare
is less interested in all the different
things that might cause mankind
misery or death and is more interested
in how we might suffer or die well
how we might find meaning or redemption
or grace
in the concrete fact that we all will
suffer
and are bound to become dust faced with
that grim reality
shakespeare turns to the higher things
to search out the springs of mercy and
justice
of love and nobility of sin and
forgiveness
but if shakespeare confronted with civil
disorder
and terrible disease was still able to
turn to higher things
perhaps that was simply because he was
shakespeare a genius unequaled in our
tradition
perhaps in his greatness we can't find
an example for ourselves
let me tell a second story that i take
from james shapiro's book
shakespeare in america in january
1846 part of the us army
found itself stationed in corpus christi
texas
to prepare for the outbreak of the
mexican-american war
corpus christi was described by one
officer as
quote the most murderous thieving
gambling cut throat god forsaken hole in
texas
and if you know texas that's saying a
lot
the troops were growing idol and
idleness and god forsaken holes
are not a good match to counteract this
john b magruder had the soldiers build a
large theater
and then organized them for the
production of several plays
shakespeare's othello among them in the
initial casting
the part of desdemona othello's
beautiful wife
was given to james longstreet the man
whom robert e lee would soon call his
old war horse
long street was a big man standing at
six foot two
more than 200 pounds and with a long
beard
they decided he didn't look quite right
for desdemona
and instead gave the part to the shorter
lighter
ulysses s grant
grant however was too bristly and the
soldier playing othello
grew frustrated complaining quote i
cannot pump up any sentiment with grant
dressed up as desdemona
they eventually sent to have a
professional actress come
and so resolved the difficulty the long
street
did note in his memoirs that grant
looked very like a girl dressed up but
he did not have much sentiment
now i admit that i share this story in
part
because i simply delight in the thought
of ulysses s grant
future president of the united states in
a
playing the gentle elegant desdemona
but the more i've thought about it the
more i've understood
the significance of this action magruder
long street grant all tough men
men of action men preparing for bloody
deeds
men who would play decisive roles in the
terrible conflict
that would determine the course of our
great nation's history
when caught in a god-forsaken hole
trying to manage soldiers and prepare
for a war
they too turned to the higher things to
the fine
and delicate domestic tragedy of othello
this wasn't just busy work for idle
hands
they could have made the soldiers dig
ditches easily enough or any other form
of manual labor
no magruder longstreet and grant were
engaged in a much harder toil
of civilizing men of building culture
of taking the finest things that have
been handed down to us
and making them live again even in texas
but if shakespeare's london or grants
corpus christi
seem too far away from us we are at
hillsdale blessed
to have a long and noble history that we
might look to as well
we all know of course our college's
great triumph during the american civil
war
when our young men went to fight for our
union and when our college nevertheless
continued its mission
to furnish all persons who wish
irrespective of
nation color or sex a literary
scientific
and theological education these are the
higher things
and our college followed its mission
even in the darkest days of our country
but given our current situation my
thoughts turned
to the hillsdale college of 1918
in the spring of that year with world
war one raging
the united states government established
the student army training corps
a program where male students at liberal
arts colleges across the country
were enlisted in a program jointly
administered by the government
and the colleges in which the young men
received both military training
and a liberal arts education the men
were formally enlisted as privates in
the u.s
army and subject to military law
additionally the us government paid
their tuition and fees
and they received a salary of thirty
dollars a month
hillsdale college was selected to host
one such program
and 195 of our young men enlisted in it
there was a barracks built right there
down manning street
in the old shoe factory the young men of
hillsdale lived in this barracks
engaged in drills parades and training
while also attending college classes
we have wonderful records in the
collegian of the goings-on
of course with the men busy in training
the collegian was mostly written by the
young women of our college
and we have many little notes about how
fine the men looked in their uniforms
and and how lonely the dining hall was
with all of the men gone
in the evenings the hillsdale women
would gather down the street to watch
the hillsdale men parade
for the lowering of the flag in the
retreat ceremony
and then return to their residences and
do what they have always done at
hillsdale college
surpassed the young men in their study
of latin and greek
but in 1918 we didn't only have a
world-rending conflict
of mind-boggling proportions we also saw
the terrible outbreak
of the infamous spanish influenza
hillsdale of course was not untouched by
the 1918
pandemic students became sick
and one of our students a young man in
the temporary barracks of the student
army training corps
died of the virus in december of that
year
he was harry kelly part of the class of
22
1922. he was 21 years old
and the collegian reports that he quote
rendered faithful
and efficient service in the student
army training court
i want to think about him for a moment
he walked
this same campus where we now sit
he saw these same hills i have trees in
my backyard
that are much older than he was and that
he might have seen
or sat under had he strolled past the
hungry howie's of yore onto norwood
avenue
why was he here what was he doing
why with the world falling apart in
disease
and war did a young man come to
hillsdale college
to enlist in the student army training
corps and study both
soldiery and the liberal arts why did he
do
this risking his very life which he duly
paid
why did the young women of the college
attend despite
the conflict and the influenza
why study latin or shakespeare or
physics at such a time
when there are so many more pressing and
practical concerns
our studies here point beyond and above
the quotidian mess of conflict and
disease
that is the constant companion of
mankind
it isn't that we ignore or dismiss the
suffering
that conflict and disease brings these
are real aspects of our existence
and we must exercise prudence and
fortitude in confronting them
as well i think as praying for the gifts
of faith hope and charity
but we must never be governed wholly by
them
to have one's actions finally determined
by conflict or disease
is to be subject to them to become slave
to them
the free man or woman the liberally
educated man or woman
always retains always the sense of that
which is higher
and finer those permanent things
those transcendent truths that rightly
order our existence
and give our lives meaning even in the
face of suffering
and so friends i can only end in
expressing my thanks and admiration
i am deeply grateful to our
administration
to our students and to the faculty and
staff
despite the tremendous headwinds we have
faced as a college
we continue to pursue our mission and
the great good
of the noble endeavor we are engaged in
with vigor
and courage i have never been so proud
to be a part of hillsdale college as in
this year
in these trying times thank you